23 on a thursday morning special
olympics nevada sports fitness
friendship and a lot of great programs
here in the valley it takes a lot to
make it all happen joining us this
morning elise pearson with special
olympics nevada good to see you once
again hey thanks for having me excited
to be here now this morning we're here
to talk about bowl for gold both for the
gold full for the goal for the gold a
bowling event happening down at sunset
station uh in about a month it's down
over in in august but we're talking
about it right now let's talk about what
this event is and how it helps raise
money for great programs here in the
valley so it's don't tell my other
events but it's one of my most favorite
events it is just a great opportunity
for team building or families to come
out and really have a good time you get
to bowl you get to interact with special
olympic athletes you get fed so it's a
super super fun day
and everything we raise for this
fundraiser does stay here in nevada to
support our local nevada athletes in
nevada schools and health programs and i
think a lot of times we talk about
special olympics and we focus on the
olympics aspect of
of the name but there's so much more
that special olympics nevada does
how else uh is the organization involved
in schools and the community aside from
just on the fields and the courts
so yeah right first off our general
sports program is the cornerstone of the
entire programming we are also in
schools with our championship schools
and unified program and we're in school
districts across the state
we also have healthy athletes which we
offer wellness nutrition and health
screening preventative health screenings
we also have athlete leadership programs
where we train our athletes to
self-advocate and speak up for
themselves
and we have youth programs that's just
so much more than just sports yeah i've
had the fortune of taking part in some
of those leadership events and uh i
apparently i'm seeing the bowl for the
gold too i should warm up my arms i
guess i'm gonna start bowling again eh
say apparently you scare me i thought no
no yeah i'll be there looking forward to
that so if if you're at home if people
at home they want to take part maybe
some folks they know what work want to
take part in the bowl for the gold event
in august how can they take part so you
can register as a team of four and or
you can register as an individual at
sonv sonv.org
we also have sponsorship opportunities
still available right now we are happy
to announce that las vegas raiders and
penta building group are both sponsors
so it's a good group to join on and that
again can be seen at sonv.org love that
so again it's both for the gold you see
there august 20th uh 11 to 2 bowling
over at sunset station right down in
henderson down in the southeast valley
right right all right good to see you
elise once again from special olympics
you've got to take part if you can it's
a great event i've been there for a
couple of times it's a wonderful
experience good to see you once again
awesome thanks